how do you overcome the fear of
rejection I'm going to answer that
question in today's episode of ask Evan
so recent asks a question for one of my
YouTube fans love you guys
Sanjaya who wrote in this a amazing
video Evan thanks Angela
I would like to get advice about fear of
rejection because most of the people
have this mindset so there's a fantastic
question and one that I think a lot of
entrepreneurs go through how to overcome
that fear of rejection I'm gonna share
with you my three tips on how to do it
number one is feel the fear and do it
anyway so what I want you to understand
is you can't get rid of that fear I
don't want you to think about how do I
completely get rid of that fear because
fear is natural fear is normal and a lot
of people they think because they're
afraid of it then they're not going to
do it so your first starting point is
understanding that it's natural to be
afraid of rejection and you don't want
to let that fear hold you back you want
to be motivated by the fear you want to
not make a decision because you're
afraid of it you know if there's an
opportunity in front of you the reason
not to do it should be something logical
something rational not because you're
afraid to do it so it's understanding
that it's okay to be afraid
feel that fear and do it anyway number
two is believe that you can help them
this is one of the biggest things that
helped me early on in my career when I
was being approached by brands who
wanted to work with me and one of the
first companies that I work with was
Microsoft and they reached out to me
said every can you help us with this
campaign that we're doing and I was so
afraid at that time because I thought
Who am I like I'm this I mean I'm
nothing compared to Microsoft what value
can I possibly give them
and I was so worried they would walk
away from the deal and they wouldn't
want to work with me and then I realized
that hey I can actually help these guys
right the value that I bring is
substantial and they're coming to me for
a reason and so this has helped me over
and over and over in my career whenever
I felt nervous or afraid or thought I
might get rejection it's not going into
a situation trying to sell somebody
something it's knowing that you really
can help them so it's believing in your
product or service and knowing that it
can actually have
really positive impact on their lives I
found that that really reduce the amount
of fear for me going into that situation
number three is change your approach I'm
a big believer in betting on your
strengths and doing things that you're
really really good at and want to learn
and not try to improve your weaknesses
and doing the stuff that you suck at and
hate because that's never the path to
build a highly successful company or for
you to be happy right if you're forcing
yourself to do stuff that you don't like
over and over and over again you're
never going to build something great or
be a happy person with your life right
and so what's causing this fear of
rejection so for example if you are
doing cold calling and you hate cold
calling and every time you look at the
phone you're looking at and say I don't
want to pick up that phone cold calling
can work and it works for some people
but it may not work for you and the
right approach may be to change your
strategy do something else that's more
comfortable for you that you excel at
that you want to be better at that
you're more passionate about and so if
you're looking at something and you're
constantly afraid of it and constantly
thinking I don't I really won't want to
do that again think is the reason I
don't want to do because you're just
afraid of it or because there's a
logical reason behind it and sometimes
the solution is just a change your
approach and do something that's best
fit for you
focus on your strengths and not your
weaknesses so remember feel the fear and
do it anyway
believe you can help them and change
your approach believe thank you so much
for watching I'd love to know how you
overcome your fear of rejection leave it
in the comments below and I look forward
to joining the discussion